if you found aladdin's lamp and could
make three wishes what would you wish
for what about an eternal life eternal
happiness and a beautiful eternal
mansion
we'll use this to make some tea for now
well
there is not a ladder's lamp not any
genie that can grant you any wishes but
if you still want eternal life an
eternal happiness and a beautiful
mansion to reside in forever then listen
carefully because you don't need genie
this is what you need the prophet
salallahu sallam said whoever builds a
message for the sake of allah allah will
build for him a similar house in jannah
are you going to say brother ali is this
one of these normal houses that we have
remember listen to me carefully what are
you talking about here this is jannah
the prophet peace be upon him said in
there are bricks of gold and silver
mortar of fragrant musk pebbles of
pearls and sapphire are you excited
relax he's going to carry on and soil of
saffron whoever enters it filled with
joy and will never feel miserable he
will live there forever and will never
die is that it no no no no no listen
their clothes would never wear out and
the youth will never fade allahu akbar
all of this can inshallah be yours with
a small sannaka of a hundred dollars
only islam net is establishing a masjid
and a community center in one of the
most northern countries of the world no
way and they urgently need your support
if you donate to build this masjid allah
will try to build a house for you in
jannah with bricks of gold and silver is
that it no we're not finished we just
started brother where are you going
ancestor this is a sadakajaria what is
sadakajaria every person who prays in
this masjid five times a day 365 days a
year every hotel that is held and
attended by hundreds if not thousands of
people
every tarawih that is prayed in ramadan
every child that memorized the quran you
will inshallah sharing that reward on
that day when allah tells us that our
books will be given and every little
atom weight of good deed you've done
will be there and imagine you see a
mountain and you're like what a lucky
person which righteous person
allah says this is for you for me yes
what did i do
you allowed people to pray you built a
masjid i never had the money to build
the message of allah you helped you gave
towards it and allah gives you the
reward of as if you've built it donate
now guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra rewards
you